hello here cesti kaufmann with my
seventh secret of language learning
and this is maybe the most
important secret and it's kind of the
combination of the other secrets and this
secret is to make yourself a learner a
student  l dependent it is very
important whether you are in school or
not it is not important
even in a class you have to
be someone independent who wants to
learn who takes charge of his
study of the language that  does that mean
good you have to look you have to
look for content you have to as I
said for example in the six other
secrets decided to put in the time
necessary to see this desire to
succeed so choose ways of  studies
who who you like so if you
like reading if you like listening
if you prefer watching videos if
you like looking for natives spoke
a little to talk with them on the
internet through skype but decide what you
like in the  not  elm don't be
passive you have to make decisions
to notice what is happening in
europe
you have to take the initiative you have to
try to see what is happening
it's this expression I already have them
seen before this structure the gg
now I understand it a little better so
you have to take the initiative
yourself to accumulate your vocabulary
too and to master yourself so
not to allow yourself to be frustrated so to
remain patient to  sourcing in
both getting all the
necessary equipment for their own success
so here are the people who are successful in
learning languages who are like me people who d
it independently or even
o to school  school and who are
in school you must in any case be
learning an independent student it is
the key to success so with that I
wish you much success in your
studies she I hope you will
come and visit us a  links and there we
po  let's continue the discussion
on language learning
thank you very much for listening to me so long
goodbye